avete mai visto una persona che spara
un'onda energetica dal buco dalle bucce
e meraviglioso belle ragazze poi minuti
questo video sono fa dj e ci sono dati
sui test perché un video che ecco
perfetto riva non danno molto soli vado
avanti i problemi gli arditi livelli non
vorrei dire ma la voragine si fa sentire
e vanta propaggine che non son riuscito
manco entrare nel livello fermi attimo
perfetto ok scelto gioco non riescono ad
entrare di cazzo di livelli sbagliando
io i comandi ci siamo ragazzi siamo
l'episodio rivolin che da qualche parte
nell'anno 2000 xx non lo so non me ne
frega un cazzo ci sono quelli ragazzi i
taxi che ci saranno nel 2000 xx c'è
proprio taxi di nuova generazione non si
capisce bene cosa sono sti cosi asparano
fantastico le anguille ave certo così
che se esattamente sta succedendo niente
ma non ci possa essere babbo ragazzi
sono diventato babbo natale ma quando è
che morte morto ragazzi babbo j non
delude un cazzo sì certo forse da quando
aladin è diventato un coso mi sembra una
cosa crescita e 25 ba ecco
e lo spirito di arabi mi è rimasta una
vita sopra chiesto lurido cioè ma che ti
stai drogando cosa ma tutto ma tutto è
la madonna e di tragedia ho vinto cos'è
nel parcheggio taxi zio beni che avevo
ragione sui taxi sono fatti apposta
questo gioco ha delle spiegazioni o e
così tutto quanto ma perché veramente
non si capisce una sega è fatto tutto
strano e tutto strano gioco che fai
sotto così ho capito e non c'è tempo per
spiegare che sarebbe il titolo del gioco
però almeno un attimino capire cosa sta
succedendo almeno quello dobbiamo
giocare a carte o mi fate passare
ditemelo qual è il problema che vuoi
andare la madonna sarà una super sayan
sono morto devo bruciare le cose poi mi
butto nell'acqua perfetto un genio io
non ho parole ragazzi come andare a
fuoco a ritmo di danza è bellissimo c'è
io non so come ho fatto a non scoprire
sto gioco prima fate uno capire ho vinto
la torcia umana reja non era esattamente
tutti vero ma devo fare veloce pure
perfetto
l'ho fatta eccolo eccolo eccolo
togliti bastardina non così che culo che
è cool lo sapevo lo sapevo
ripeto per l'ennesima volta se non ci
fossero i check point suo gioco sai
avrei ammazzato qualcuno ovviamente
questa roba è
su katemi il birillo le olè olè dai che
vinco ma non ci credo mai mi sembra più
che ovvia andiamo incontro un babbo
natale che non sa neanche chi cazzo sta
facendo ma arriva dal futuro sembra mai
plausibile che mi fa incazzare per una
testa a preservativo ma cosa indecente
mai forza si può cambiare il suo cazzo
di cappello vi prego chi cazzo ma come
mai forse è meglio quando quando vado a
fuoco perso tutto perfetto
il sonno volpi ficato di nuovo
fantastico con dagioni barca [ __ ]
tempismo tempismo bravo più veloce di
così ragazzi non impossibile ma è
veramente assurdo
ok non so perché ma il credevo che
quello splat mi avesse ucciso invece
meglio effetto l'importante ragazza non
è stata una volta ma arrivare all'uva
avvincente 1015 già fatta
ma cosa ma cosa scendi bravo e là di
quale era il problema
sì sì ok ok cani calmi se muoio mi
girano le palle abbastanza credetemi
no no benedetto xvi addio
oddio cosa ho fatto ragazzi dove sono le
mie fottute medaglie non so neanche io
cosa ho fatto come perché ma va bene
cosi mostri cosi che bello perfetto
dove vai dove cazzo vai vai dalla nonna
zio non hai perfetto qual è il problema
sono deficiente ma per questo lo
sapevate regata ci siamo mangerò ma ciao
fratello soffre di mal di gola ben
active viola ragazzi a don beccari lo
stomaco
no perché sono un [ __ ] avevo andati
sotto dove ho capito ho capito
ok ma come salgo così sto fijo nanì non
ha capito lo zio come funzionano le cose
che ci penso io regala ai giu perfetto
suo ma allora si [ __ ] nel cervello
ma qual è il tuo problema all'anima
fammi capire ma è bravissimo ad esso in
uso brown madonna cosa ho fatto perché
ce la sto facendo
non so come noa devi andare su su un
bravissimo
oddio oddio c'è l'ansia
no no sono [ __ ] sono [ __ ] qua
sono [ __ ] quattro ragazzi quali
siano peggio tra questi boss e quelli di
super meat boy fa sapere che bella alito
pesante la smetti di spararmi ti devo
uscire alla famiglia la rowe grazie
molto gentile a [ __ ] grazie è
perfetto dove vai vai vai vai vai vai
vai vai la peggio
bravissimo sono morto
se mangiano un impatto no ma [ __ ]
cos'è cos'è perché i cag i mattoni che
problema è alla testa a lui ha deciso
così raga ha deciso di pagare mattoni di
punto in bianco perfetto ragazzi non
muore mai però anche cazzo è un verso e
menziona che si fa allora credo che mi
sia venuta in mente una cosa forte se
cosiddetta termina attimo
crepa si ma vero ma cosa ma mi state
prendendo per il culo quattro ore che
faccio sta stronzata e poi devo fare
ecco perché il ragazzo honda si è morto
è morto è morto tranquilli che è morto
dove vado
ok è un casino
ve lo dico che un bene va bene ma se fai
spuntare anche satana magari la forza di
goku e con me club si è morto è morto è
la madonna che cazzo diventato un
cappello o in his face con un suk a
proprio ai ragazzi che stavo per
incazzarmi che lasciam perdere abbiamo
vinto altre stronzate di livelli magari
la prossima volta
evitiamo e grazie cos'è sta cagata alla
lavatrice cazzo mi serviva il bucato
cos'è un giorno è un po la chiave di
camera mia questo è più o meno salve mi
servirò lo premiamo il pulsante che
voleva bene forse non è la macchina di
papà questa con in un laboratorio così
bene
[Risate]
quanti schiaffi che cazzo era sfruttata
la la faccia da colpe a caso va bene
niente ragazzi sono gli occhi ma che
figo scopriremo nei prossimi episodio
ragazzi per ora lascio perdere perché mi
fa veramente strano queste ragazzine che
possono chiudere quindi d'un quali
giovani insomma la volpe perché merita e
quindi ragazzi servito mi è piaciuto la
sete lasciato mentre il piace anche la
pagina di facebook che condivido attuata
la descrizione sono resi distretto cv
diavolo e la volpe che mi distrae e noi
ci rimettiamo alla ragazza